tonight at 10 a rare glimpse of China's
ambitious expansion in one of the
world's most contested regions we report
from the South China Sea where the
Chinese are warning off anyone who comes
too close to their building program we
continue our look this morning on what
China does not want you to see the
United States as the superpower is
reclaiming land in the South China Sea
the fact that we're dealing with the
situation right now where we the U.S has
to be much more aggressive in dealing
with the Chinese government CNN has
learned that the U.S Navy is about to
send a destroyer there let's go to our
CNN Chief CNN got exclusive access to
classified U.S surveillance flights over
the islands
the threat of China is becoming big news
the media is beating the drums of War as
the world is being primed to regard
China as a new enemy China's alarming
creation of entirely new territory in
the South China Sea is one part of a
broader military push that some fear is
to challenge U.S dominance in the region
China is building airstrips in the South
China Sea on disputed Islands condemned
by an international Tribunal
this is now a flash point for war
between China and America
[Music]
what is not news is that China itself is
under threat
these American bases form a giant noose
encircling China with missiles bombers
warships all the way from Australia
through the Pacific to Asia and Beyond
I mean if you were in Beijing looking
out you stood on the tallest building in
Beijing and looked out at the Pacific
Ocean you'd see American warships you'd
see Guam is about to sink because
there's so many missiles pointed at
China you'd look up a Korean see
American armaments pointing at China
you'd see Japan which is basically uh
Japan's a glove over the American fist I
think if I was Chinese I'd have a little
to worry about about American
aggressiveness
and we have China surrounded and we're
doing more all the time to try and keep
it surrounded and deepen that
containment of China
uh but China presents a fascinating case
of a country that is independent doesn't
have foreign basis on its territory
growing very rapidly not as rapidly now
as it did for 30 years but still the
second ranking economy in the world we
have an adversary and that adversary is
China and that adversary uh unless there
is dramatic reform inside China
will be our enemy someday one myth I
think really that needs to be dispelled
was that somehow
China is aiming to replace America and
and going to run the world it's not well
first of all the Chinese are not that
stupid the West
with its Christian
roots or about
converting other people into their
beliefs
the Chinese are not about that it's it's
just the co I'm I again I'm not
degrading the Western culture I'm just
pointing out the inherent nature the DNA
is of two different cultures the Chinese
two thousand years ago built the Great
Wall
to keep the barbarians out not to invade
them
as the world's economic power moves
rapidly to Asia the response of the
United States is to deploy the majority
of its Naval forces to Asia and the
Pacific
this massive military buildup is known
in Washington as the pivot to Asia
the target is China
the great power game in the 21st century
is called Perpetual War
America's unchallenged arms industry the
annual prize is huge profits from almost
600 billion dollars of military spending
I've been on Star Wars the
electromagnetic gun is now reality
you're sitting there thinking about
these next generation and futuristic
ideas and we've got scientists who have
designed these and it's coming to life
and the smartest weapons need enemies
as a Pacific Nation the United States
will play a larger and long-term role in
shaping this region and its future I
have directed my National Security team
to make our presence and Mission in the
Asia Pacific a top priority
in one sense
is the U.S already at war with China yes
on the ground and in the air the winner
of the Nobel Peace Prize President
Barack Obama has committed to trillions
of dollars of uh to our nuclear Arsenal
he's committing trillions of future
dollars to war and space and we need an
enemy for all this money and China is
the perfect enemy
the aim of this film is to break a
silence the United States and China May
well be on a path to war and nuclear war
is no longer unthinkable
in a few years China has become the
world's second biggest economic power
the United States is the world's biggest
military power with bases and missiles
and ships covering every continent every
ocean
China is a threat to this dominance as
Washington but who is the threat this
film is about shifting power and great
danger it's also a film about the human
Spirit and the rise of an extraordinary
resistance among people on the front
line of a coming War where the words
never again have an urgent meaning for
all of us
foreign
[Music]
this is Bikini the rim of an ancient
underwater volcano in the Marshall
Islands
with its necklace of 23 Islands bikini
is a place of beauty and silence
and Menace
look closely where the emerald Lagoon
suddenly falls into a vast black hole
this is the crater of one of the
greatest man-made explosions the
hydrogen bomb they call Bravo
it vaporized an entire Island and
poisoned almost everything and everyone
as our plane flew low we seem to touch
its deathly void
the Marshall Islands lie in the vast
Pacific Ocean between the United States
and Asia
captured from the Japanese in World War
II they've long been America's strategic
secret it's stepping stone to Asia and
China
[Music]
people here sustain themselves for
thousands of years
with abundant fish breadfruit and
coconuts
[Music]
oh
they were skilled Navigators who sailed
by the Stars
westerners might call this paradise
[Music]
or
all that changed in 1946 when the United
States took over the Marshall Islands as
a trust territory with an obligation to
protect the health and well-being of the
people
a nightmare began the islands were
turned into laboratory for the testing
of nuclear weapons and the people into
guinea pigs
Crossroads scene 24 take two
in this propaganda film the bikini
Islanders are being deceived unknown to
them plans were already underway to
destroy their Paradise forever
will you ask King Judah that the United
States government now wants to attempt
to turn this great destructive force
into something good for mankind and that
these experiments here at bikini are the
first step in that direction
[Music]
tell them that's fine everything being
in God's hands it must be good
[Music]
87 Ships Take positions three miles off
bikini to suffer the shattering impact
of the fifth atomic bomb here in a
murder of Warships was assembled in
bikini Lagoon in order to blow them to
bits
the decks of the 73 test chips anchored
in bikini Lagoon are scenes of feverish
activity as scientists plot experimental
programs designed to furnish data on
blast effects of the mighty atom bar
animals of many animals were strapped to
their decks like a perverse
the experiment was to see how they died
how they burned
special ointments are applied to
determine their protective quality other
parts of the exposed areas being left
bare to the atom blast three two
[Music]
foreign
big on bikini today is disturbing ghosts
I struggle through the jungle to the
bunker where they press the button at 6
45 on the morning of the h-bomb test
now claimed by the undergrowth it's like
a Subterranean Temple to Modern Times
they drank milkmaid powdered milk
Lucky Strike cigarettes and later this
sign was erected that's beyond irony
it says please leave this property as
you find it thank you for your kindness
and understanding
give their all for their art and you can
just bet that audience is giving with
the wolf calls in the bikini named after
the atomic explosion in the Pacific
bikini was an explosion everywhere
in 1946 the bikini swimsuit was launched
to celebrate the nuclear explosions that
it destroyed life on Bikini Island
the inventor of the bikini a Frenchman
made his fortune
today a bikini body is promoted in
magazines as an object of desire and
good health
the bodies of the people of bikini and
other islands are the most irradiated in
the world
all these women have had thyroid cancer
um
foreign
[Music]
radiation poisons the food and water
our shoes registered unsafe on a geiger
counter
the abandoned Cemetery looks out to
where the sun rose one morning then rose
again as apocalypse
the equivalent of one Hiroshima bomb was
exploded in these islands every day for
12 years
Beauty has returned to the island but
the people happened
exiled Barren Islands many of them
starve
in 1968 president Lyndon Johnson told
them it was safe to go home
but it wasn't safe and the U.S
authorities knew it wasn't safe
accident
yes
what happened as a result of the Bravo
test was that a cover-up was launched
very shortly after March 1
I mean there's such a history of wrong
information outright lies deception
there was no no attempt to take the most
conservative approach and make sure that
everybody was okay they knew for the
radioactive fallout was going to go uh
and they took that risk and went ahead
and detonated the bomb knowing full well
which way it's gonna go uh they still
had an opportunity to evacuate even on
the day of the shot but these people
were not evacuated we were not evacuated
and the people on new Drake were not
back
so it only leads one one up uh one to
believe it number one the United States
needed some guinea pigs to study what
the uh the effects of radiation would do
and that's a pretty strong indication
that the United States knew that
it seems extraordinary here we are this
far end of the 21st century talking to
people still frightened of all that
nuclear fallout all those tests all
those years ago
the impression I get is that there's so
little trust among people the US is
trying to provide as much information as
much good information as we can and so I
wouldn't accept the characterization
that uh that there have been lies and
and cover-ups the word guinea pigs comes
up a lot from these survivors I would I
would refer you to our Embassy website
on that I've read it and uh that that
question was looked at during the
Clinton Administration and that was not
the conclusion they came to
the secret of the Marshall Islands is
Project 4.1
Declassified documents reveal a
scientific program that began as a study
of mice and became a study of human
beings exposed to radiation
Chicago is where it all began and to the
aec Argonne labs in Chicago last week
came seven men natives of the Marshall
Islands
he and the rest were irradiated by our
March 1954 hydrogen bomb test
John is mayor of rangola which is 100
miles from bikini
John as we said is a Savage but a happy
amenable Savage his grandfather ran
almost naked on his Coral at home
the white man brought money and religion
and the market for his Copa John Reeds
knows about God and is a pretty good
mayor
The Iron Room is a radiation detector
for human beings
inside John the mayor whose first visit
to the white man's country meant San
Francisco cable cars and Chicago
skyscrapers and streamlined trains
first visit to the white man's country
meant The Iron Room
a Savage governs his life by rituals
and he understands this because he
thinks of it as a new ritual sitting
alone inside the room
outside strange kind of priest and a
long white coat when the ritual of The
Iron Room was over for John it began for
the others as each finish he was told it
was over and he was given apples not a
good things to eat
then he took off the ritual clothing and
the Seven men put on the suits and
thought codes they had been lent in
Hawaii which they would return in Hawaii
on their way back in the Marshall
Islands in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean
United States government documents
clearly demonstrate that its scientists
conducted human radiation experiments
with marshally citizens
some of our people were injected with or
coerced to drink
fluids laced with radiation
other experimentation involved the
purposeful and premature resettlement of
people on Islands highly contaminated by
weapons cysts to study how human beings
absorb radiation from their foods and
environment
[Music]
these people are guinea pigs they are
part of the experiment project 4.1
they're being returned to rongolab and I
learned a hundred miles from bikini by
the U.S Navy
they were told repeatedly it was safe to
go home
[Music]
epic couple believed they were going
home to safety
the man is John and Jane the mayor of
wrong galap the happy Savage from The
Iron Room in Chicago
his wife is mature and this is their
baby son lekage
they had no idea of the horror that lay
ahead
they are being returned to an island
described by a U.S atomic energy
official
as by far the most contaminated place on
Earth
he added it will be interesting to get a
measure of human uptake when people live
in a contaminated environment
the people of rongola remained on their
poison Island for 28 years as guinea
pigs
the objects of regular scientific
examination
[Music]
already
is
foreign
[Music]
ERS pleaded with the U.S authorities to
move them to safety as evidence emerged
that the second generation the children
were also poisoned
yeah
desperate to leave the island is called
on Greenpeace to rescue this ship the
Rainbow Warrior moved the entire
population to an uncontaminated island
they called it operation Exodus
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Dr Robert Connor a leading
medical scientist of Brookhaven National
Laboratories
Conor devoted his distinguished career
to examining the Islanders
he wrote the habitation of these people
on the island will afford the most
valuable ecological radiation data on
human beings
the various radio isotopes present can
be traced from the soil to the food
chain and into human beings
Dr conard gained the trust of whole
communities when he brought the
Islanders to New York to be examined he
showed them the sights and had them over
for a barbecue foreign
[Music]
son lekage died aged 18. Dr conard sent
the man they called a Savage a sympathy
card from your friend
Bob
in 1957 Majora and Jane was The Smiling
young woman seen here on her way back to
wrong galap unaware of the danger she
and her family faced
this is Madura 28 years later grieving
the death of her son lekage from
radiation poisoning
foreign
[Music]
like her son and her husband majour died
from a virulent cancer
I don't see any
great clinics that have been established
by if not the department of energy
certainly not by the US government
there's a clinic downtown in Montrose
there's also a whole whole body counter
you can have the plutonium in your body
measured as well anyone can for free
this is the plutonium measuring shop
where they'll tell you how radioactive
you are
people waiting to be tested are welcome
with a video showing their Islands being
blown up
and this reassuring commentary
Bill Jackson program manager
of the Department of energy duee
Marshall Islands program
this is renok a refugee from The
Poisoned island of rongolap whose
family-owned land and lived a secure
prosperous life
now she lives in a Shack in the capital
Majuro with her children and
grandchildren
she has no water no Sanitation
would give it with you I mean you
probably don't do a new moon
and power she has electricity
in 1986 the United States granted
limited Independence to the Marshall
Islanders on condition but they accepted
a mere 150 million dollars compensation
for the damage caused by nuclear testing
acclaims tribunal was set up and soon
ran out of money an appeal to the U.S
Congress more than a decade ago still
awaits a reply
Darlene caju Johnson was a young Health
worker who became the champion of her
people after she discovered the full
extent of their suffering caused by
nuclear testing that many more Islands
were poison than the Americans plane
this remarkable speech in 1983 broke the
silence I bring greetings
from the Marshall Islands and throughout
Micronesia
we have hundreds of women who are
miscarriages we have leukemia cancers we
have thyroid cancers we have still Birds
babies we have nowadays I just come back
from home and I have talked to many
women and men in the population
that we have babies we call jellyfish
babies a baby is born on a labor table
and it moves up and down like this it's
a color of her ugly thing it does not
shave like a human being it moves up and
downs like this on a labor table because
that thing is breathing that is a baby
in 1982
Darlene married Giff Johnson
the author of this tribute to his wife
Darlene was one of the liveliest most
entertaining individuals that I have
ever had the pleasure of knowing
he was a voice for the voiceless
like so many Marshall Islanders
Darlene died of cancer
age 45
this is the largest of the Island's
kwajalein occupied by one of America's
most important and secretive bases
known as the Ronald Reagan test site
it's a missile launch pad that commands
the Pacific Ocean all the way to Asia
and China
[Music]
here the people of the Marshall Islands
are once again being subjected to the
testing of weapons of mass destruction
designed for a coming War
[Music]
this is part of a remarkable plan
known as Vision 2020
devised in the 1990s its aim is
described officially as full spectrum
dominance
this means control of all land sea air
cyberspace and space five four
three two one ignition
from California almost 5 000 miles away
the U.S Air Force tests its
InterContinental missiles by firing them
at the Marshall Islands
imagine a missile coming screaming out
of the sky it's absolutely terrifying
there I think that there's there's
really nothing
that that I can imagine that that would
be more terrifying than this and and
we're talking about
devices that any one of them could go
off course
none of this disturbs life on the base
we're small town America has been
recreated a Wonderland of the Suburban
good life
enjoy it thank you thank you
[Applause]
fabulous but there's nothing better than
living on a tropical island I pretty
much have beachfront property you know
it's great I love it here
just across the bay is eBay Island
known as the slum of the Pacific more
than 12 000 people live here on a strip
of land less than a mile long
many of them refugees from what is now
the missile base and from Ireland's
Poison by nuclear testing
every day people from eBay are brought
to work on the missile base to water the
gardens and the golf course
[Applause]
then they are ferried back to their
poverty
[Music]
this is apartheid in the Pacific
thank you
[Music]
if I need a lot of things getting
medicine education and job vegetable and
fruits
vegetable and fruits yes here we are at
the tropical island and you need
vegetable and fruit yes
fish vegetables and fruit were once
abundant on eBay
today fish is contaminated by toxic
pollutants said the Environmental
Protection Agency
now the only food most people can afford
is processed and imported
they have the highest rate of diabetes
in the world
when someone gets really ill
do they go to the hospital over on the
base because
they've got a pretty modern Clinic over
there they don't treat treat them with
medicine
they just go there for taking the blood
and then the X-ray so what happens when
somebody is seriously ill
they cannot do anything
the most consistent
example given is the example of the
Ronald Reagan missile site and eBay next
to it
on the Ronald Reagan missile site
there's a vivid example of the United
States golf courses and uh
swimming pools and all kinds of manatees
um right next to it is what is called
the slum of the Pacific it's a it's a
challenge e by uh is in great need right
now we've talked about infrastructure
one of the projects the U.S is working
with our Australian colleagues and with
the Asia Development Bank is a sewer and
water project desperately needed for
ebuy ebuy is overcrowded the schools
need repair actually the U.S military
did a survey back in the 70s and found
that the sewers didn't work and the
water didn't run and the electricity
wasn't there it only happened not all
that long ago they found almost exactly
the same thing why why hasn't that been
fixed there's complete agreement that
ebuy should be a priority and not only
because of the the current activities of
the Ronald Reagan space and missile
defense site but there's also now an
additional component that is providing
for Global Security and that's the space
fence project by the Air Force
every missile fired on the Marshall
Islands by the U.S military costs 100
million dollars each
this derelict school bus is the only one
on eBay
they can't afford to replace it
a base is not good for us the people of
Marshall Islands we have no need for it
it's being used to test missiles to fire
countries like China
yes
and anywhere else if they want to
what would you like to see happen there
I want our land back
[Music]
this is Shanghai the historic port on
the Yangtze River China's greatest City
I had arranged to meet the American
author James Bradley whose latest
especelling book The China Mirage
reveals an extraordinary hidden history
of American power and modern China
it was almost illegal for someone like
me to know a Chinese for almost all of
American History the Chinese came to
America to mine gold and build the
railroads and Americans decided we
didn't like the competition so in 1882
we had the Chinese Exclusion acts which
kept the Chinese out of the United
States for about a hundred years so you
have the largest population in the world
that can't come to the United States so
at just the point we're putting up the
Statue of Liberty saying we welcome
everybody we were erecting a wall saying
we welcome everybody except those
Chinese
fear of arising China today is the
latest chapter in a history of
propaganda that presented the Chinese as
uncouth and infantile
to Western popular and political culture
the Chinese became the yellow peril
and racial stereotypes for the constant
theme of fear and threat
Forest color as the evil fool Manchu his
passion for power twisting His Brilliant
mind
as he Revels in the horrors of human
sacrifice and tortured
[Music]
behind the mask of full men too
this character tour of an entire people
concealed another agenda
opium
for the American Elite
Elite 19th century China was a gold mine
of drugs
Warren Delano the grandfather of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was the
American opium king of China he was the
biggest American opium dealer second to
the British he welcomed the first
American ship into China to help out
with the Opium Wars much of the east
coast of America Colombia Harvard Yale
Princeton uh were born from opium money
the American Industrial Revolution was
funded by huge pools of money where did
this come from it came from illegal
drugs in the biggest Market in the world
China let me get this right the
grandfather of arguably
the most liberal president
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
was a drug Runner yes sir Franklin
Delano Roosevelt never made much money
in his life he had public service jobs
that were very lowly paid but he had
yahtz he had summer homes he had
mansions in New York City the kids went
to private schools he inherited a
fortune from Warren Delano his father
who was the American opium king of China
if you scratch anyone with the name
Forbes in in their name John uh Forbes
Kerry secretary of state John Forbes
Gary that's the president secretary of
state yes sir you'll find opium money
his great-grandfather was an opium
dealer
how big was opium money opium money
built the first industrial city in the
United States Lowell Massachusetts it
built the first five railroads in the
United States opium money all over the
East Coast but it wasn't talked about it
was called the China trade and if you go
to various museums you can see teas and
silks
exhibited and they keep quiet about all
that big opium money
in the scramble to get opium money China
was invaded and colonized by Britain and
the other Imperial powers
foreign armies grabbed pulse waves of
China
this is the American Army in Tiananmen
Square P King in 1900
great cities like Shanghai were taken
over and declared concessions
and foreigners lived a life of privilege
and luxury amidst terrible poverty
imposed on the Chinese
[Music]
a resistance known as the Boxer
Rebellion was put down with the savagery
rape of China set the tone for how China
was perceived in the west well into the
20th century
this is the distinguished historian
Theodore H white an advisor to the White
House
speaking in the 1960s
perhaps China is too vast to be governed
by Mercy
yet if Chinese mind craves order
they must be brought to recognize they
are the biggest factor in the world's
disorder
and we must untangle
The Madness of their mind
the most difficult task in the world is
to reach the minds of men who hate you
what white was really complaining about
was the loss of a China that the
imperial West could dominate
and the defeat of General Chiang
Kai-shek
who were these famously powerful
Christian wife mailing sung guarded
America's interests in China
that is until they were thrown out in
1949 by a Communist Revolution led by
Mao Zedong
three times in huge battles involving
millions of combatants Mao was a winner
in this contest from the early 1930s on
but we knew very little about it and
people don't understand that even today
Shanghai hears the message clearly as
foreign businessmen board up their shops
go now go quickly for communism marches
take what you can but flee in pelmel
haste the Western Powers Evacuate the
city they have built for good and bad
alike must leave
the businessman come for profit as well
as missionaries come to heal must say
goodbye as out the Yangtze esteems the
last of Western influence I farewell to
a century
today it's difficult to understand the
Paranoia ignited by Mao's Revolution
as we look at China on the map
we can see that China is the basic cause
of all of our troubles in Asia I believe
that for the sake of our safety
it is necessary to be prepared for the
possibility
of a Chinese missile attack from the
United States
[Music]
one of the myths about now
is that he was an implacable enemy of
the capitalist West
[Music]
Shanghai today is a prosperous
International City
still run by the Communists at least in
May
[Music]
when I was lost in China more than a
generation ago the loudest noise was the
tinkling of bicycle bells now just died
the streets were dark the universities
were closed the chaos of the cultural
revolution had given way to a great
silence
we're exhausted was the freest comment I
heard
coming back the change is barely
comprehensible
here in Shanghai the freedom Bears no
comparison yes there are issues with
human rights especially the right to
speak against the state and challenge
its power since I was last here millions
of people have been lifted out of
poverty many of them into an entirely
new middle class
this epic is still barely understood in
the West
or should that be willfully
misunderstood
the truth is that China has matched
America at its own great game of
capitalism
and that is Unforgivable
[Music]
picture of China's new capitalism
run rich list
this league table of China's Mega rich
is published by Rupert hoogenworth an
oldertonian whose Chinese name is harun
he's received many awards including
China's Man of the Year
this year 2015 has probably been the
most extraordinary year of wealth
creation in the history of China again
you know in I've been doing this list
for 15 16 years I've never seen a
yearlet 2015. you know normally for 200
million pounds or 300 million dollars we
find say about 800 000 people this year
2015 is is doubled there'll be more
dollar billionaires known about in China
than in the US so the U.S up until now
has been the leader in terms of business
and you know the most successful
business tycoons in the world
China 2015 would have overtaken the US
so amazing
the China is full of telling ironies not
least this Museum that was once the
house where Mao and his comrades
secretly found of the Communist Party of
China in 1921.
[Music]
today it stands in the heart of an
exclusive Ferry capitalist shopping
district
when you leave the shrine to China's
great Revolution you're confronted by a
surreal spectacle for right outside
where the Chinese Communist party was
born are the very symbols of capitalism
Starbucks apple Cartier Dolce Cabana
and down there perhaps the free Market's
greatest Triumph bottled water that
ensures you live young costing six
pounds for a small bottle in my hotel
wooden Mouse spin in his tomb if he was
here
I'm not so sure hidden history is always
a key to the truth five years before his
great Communist Revolution in 1949 Mao
sent this secret message to Washington
China must industrialize right now this
can only be done by free enterprise
Chinese and American interests fit
together economically and politically
America need not fear that we will not
be cooperative
we cannot risk Crossing America
we cannot risk any conflict
Mao received no reply
nothing has changed
Mao zeitong was looking to be a friend
with the United States from the
beginning
Mao says I will go meet Franklin
Roosevelt in the White House Mao reaches
out in 1950 to Harry Truman he reaches
out to Dwight Eisenhower his hand was
tossed away
this opportunity that might have changed
history prevented Wars saved countless
lives was lost because the truth of
Mao's overtures was denied in the
Washington of the 1950s
State Department officials who had
carried Mao's messages were condemned
unjustly as communist traitors
everybody who knew Mao who spoke Chinese
was gone in the 1950s the state
department had no employees who spoke
Chinese
it's resulted in us not having relations
with the number one most populous
country in the world
in 1979 this man dang Zao ping
became China's Paramount leader he said
socialism does not mean shared poverty
this was code for the most radical
reform since Mao's Revolution
the return of capitalism to China but
this time controlled by the Communist
Party
to be rich is glorious Dane was reported
as saying
America was now threatened by the
emergence of a vast image of itself
this is one of the many very exclusive
gated communities in Shanghai where an
apartment is one of the prizes of the
new communism
I'd arranged to see Professor zhangwei
Wei a close Aid to the late dengzao ping
the man who changed China
done is
really extremely
long-term Visionary leader with
exceeding long-term and strategic vision
for his country for his people right
China still following that path yeah
actually this is really a tradition from
China's long history you look at even
like Mao you know he said we should you
know surpass UK by which year we shall
supply United States by which year so
the tradition continues to this the Euro
Xi Jinping today is also doing the same
actually what many Chinese have problems
with Western media is this the
stereotypes about China if you are you
are content with stereotypes you miss so
many things you know if BBC broadcasts
something they are happy to always
mention this Communist dictatorship this
autocracy no actually with this cartoon
lady so you know you cannot understand
this China as it is but if you watch BBC
or cam or read economists
and try to understand China it will be a
failure it's impossible
multiple parties fight for political
power and everyone voting on them that's
the only path to Salvation to the
long-suffering necessary
educated in America and typical of a new
confident outspoken Chinese political
class now in China uh there are a lot of
problems uh but at the moment
the Chinese the party state has proven
an extraordinary ability to change
I mean I make the joke how in America
you can change political parties but you
can't change policies
in China you cannot change the party but
you can change policies uh so in a 65 or
66 years China is being run by one
single party yet
the political changes that have taken
place in China in this past 66 years
have been wider and broader and greater
than probably any other major country in
modern memory so in that time China
ceased to be communist is that what
you're saying well
China is a market economy and it's a
vibrant market economy but it is not a
capitalist country here's why
there's no way
a group of billionaires
could control the poly Bureau
us billionaires control
American policy making
so in China you have a vibrant market
economy but capital
does not rise above political Authority
capital is not does not have enshrined
rights
in America capital
the interest of capital and capital
itself has risen above the The American
Nation
the political Authority cannot check the
power of capital
and that's why America is a capitalist
country but China is not
this is the ironic title of a
best-selling book by Zhang Leisure a
journalist and critic who lives in
Beijing
many Americans imagine that the Chinese
people live a miserable repressed life
with no Freedom whatsoever
that's not quite true if you speak too
many ordinary Chinese people they will
tell you they feel their life are quite
free some 500 million people being
lifted after poverty and someone would
say probably 600 million people that's a
great achievement
for many Americans the yellow apparel
has never left them I think of the there
is the fear about China of course
there's a fear of China's rapid rise but
it also has a lot to do
with China's
the label as a communist and State
China's objectives are modest
compare with their weight
they're not trying to run the world
they're not even trying to run Asia
Pacific
I think they want to keep America from
dominating the Asia Pacific so they have
what they believe is their rightful
place in Asia Pacific because the long
civilization law history and their size
so their objectives are really modest
compared with their capacity
the the wealth the New Wealth in China
they often say this is this is the
product of
self-made entrepreneurial skill but is
it not also the product of the
exploitation of people at the bottom
what are known in China as migrants but
they're not really migrants they're
Chinese if you really you know uh
go to talk to these migrant workers you
will find quite surprisingly
over the past five to seven years
they have experienced
greater income increase than any other
social groups China not the class
Society
but China is a class Society
these are the homes of Migrant workers
people who build and service the new
China
[Applause]
here it's not uncommon for three
families to share one tiny flat
you know you would associate a socialist
country with you call with equality but
unfortunately since the reform has
started China has become one of the most
unequal Society in the world the income
gap is widening government I feel have
retreated some of the responsibilities
left the markets to take over but the
market does not always treat women
kindly some private companies that would
just refuse to hire and child's bearing
age women and sometimes when women
become pregnant they will stack them
because they don't want to pay the
motility leave and in fact the income
gap has grown much bigger between men
and women
your old boss
thanks her ping presided over the
Bloodshed in Tiananmen Square what would
you
say to the survivors of Tiananmen Square
because so many of those did fight for
what they saw as Democratic change in
China
in 1989
there were two political forces
one was those represented by the Chinese
students
their hero was mihai Gorbachev who
happened to be in Beijing their slogan
was Soviet unions today channels
tomorrow so the idea was political
reform first as a reform second
otherwise China would be hopeless yeah
and then this message was opposite he
saw a gorbacher was an idiot yeah he
thought you know a China must have
economic reform first as a reform second
this priority must be set clearly
unfortunately at that particular Moment
In 1989 the two political forces could
not reach a compromise
so definitely a tragedy occurred yeah
it was more than a tragedy it was a
massacre
of which The Memory Remains a raw
presence in modern China
why does the Chinese State still fear
the few
the few who speak out and I'm thinking
of Lucia ball exactly I mean you know as
the man won the Nobel priest prize and
and he's in prison he's a violent in
Chinese law you know by did March so
actually the freedom of expression
similar views are aired by many people
but he's really going to the extreme
challenged the government to implement
Democratic reforms
and has spent a total of 13 years in
prison
why can't a confident China
accept a criticism like this
committee makes huge mistake the oh the
Chinese an explanation if you cross the
line cross you a value the Constitution
you write so many laws you should be
punished
[Music]
and yet in China today the spirit of
protest and descent lives on in
different forms
in 2015 strikes and Community protests
and activism reach record levels
this resistance is seldom reported in
the West
so there are lots of protests in China
typically for example land being grabbed
by officials to for commercial
development and the farmers are not
being compensated properly but the
farmers now know
more aware of their rights to the
protests or young workers from the
factory they demand a better wage or
better better working condition but many
of the protests they are economic driven
not political driven they are Regional
not nationalized so this kind of things
are unlikely develop into real movement
or so-called you call that Revolution
so the Mars Revolution was the last
Revolution
what never said never
the Japanese island of Okinawa is
occupied by 32 military installations
from here the United States has attacked
Korea Vietnam Cambodia Afghanistan Iraq
is full of planes and helicopters
wherever people go they are fenced in
and told to keep out
Okinawa is the front line of a beckoning
War
with China
[Music]
aged 87 fumako shimabakuro is one of the
leaders of a non-violent resistance
that's challenging Washington's pivot to
Asia
oh come on
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
quarter of the civilians on the island
were killed in the American invasion in
and the fear of War has been passed
through the generations
[Music]
today those who witness these Horrors
live in a place of extraordinary beauty
surrounded by coral reefs and a unique
marine life
[Music]
foreign
Bay that the survivors of World War II
sought refuge and it's this they're now
fighting to save
it's an epic struggle that pits these
island people against the greatest
military power on Earth
this is the office of a former governor
of Okinawa
Otto masahidi
what he has done is create not so much a
museum
but an appeal to the outside world to
understand the resistance in Okinawa to
understand the suffering
to read its hidden history
it begins in 1945 when the Americans
invaded here is General MacArthur
arriving in Okinawa
a second invasion happened 10 years
later in what became known as the
bulldozers and balance campaign American
forces seize Prime agricultural land
burned farm houses and kill livestock
the dispossessed people of Okinawa
marched the length of Japan appealing
for help
this wall is devoted to a resistance in
Okinawa that never ceases everywhere
people go on the island they are
confronted by this sign it tells them
they must not go past this fence top
with barbed wire these fences run like
great ribbons across the island
and the bases themselves cut sways
across Okinawa but all around them are
people with this continuing
demonstration this continuing resistance
and they have a message
it's people of the world
watch what Japan and the US are doing
don't let them Force the bases on
Okinawa
Santo
foreign
all this will be lost when much of the
bay becomes concrete runways for bombers
at Camp Schwab the huge U.S Marine base
behind this fence
in 2014
Okinawa elected a new governor
takishi onaka who won by a landslide on
one issue stopping the new base at
honoka
this was election night outside the
American base at Camp schwa
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the New Year's celebration of their
victory was bittersweet
the government in Tokyo presented this
unprecedented challenge to its Authority
the issue is now in the Japanese courts
Japan's prime minister Shinzo Abbey has
also made clear that with the backing of
his powerful Patron America he wants to
reawaken Japanese nationalism and
reclaim its military power
[Music]
while we were filming the ceremony
outside the base on a day when people
paid respect to their departed loved
ones giant American helicopters circled
above us
intimidating as always
[Music]
the threat of these low-flying aircraft
is a constant presence in Okinawa
teachers often can't teach because of
the noise and the fear
this was the Carnage when an American
fighter crashed into a primary school
after the pilot had ejected to safety
[Music]
Haru Akira eight seven was terribly
burned
so today I know
foreign
you understand
me
Akira suffered throughout his youth and
died from his injuries
age 21.
another tragedy waits to happen on
Okinawa U.S military aircraft have been
involved in 44 accidents on the island
the latest threat is this hybrid plane
the Osprey notorious for its safety
issues
[Music]
thank you
wherever the military is based in Asia
there is a relationship with local
people especially women that often
breathes resentment
in Okinawa this resentment ignited a
riot in 1970
scores of American GIS were pulled from
their cars which were set alight
for Washington and its compliant Ally in
Tokyo it's this kind of insurrection
that they fear
[Music]
during the making of This film a young
woman was raped and murdered allegedly
by an American military contractor from
one of the bases
[Music]
it was the latest of thousands of cases
of violence and it brought massive
crowds into the streets not demanding an
end to the military occupation of their
country
[Music]
foreign
designed to carry a nuclear warhead
during the Cold War the United States
secretly installed nuclear weapons at
this launch pad in Okinawa
most of them were aimed at China
today the nuclear missile site is run by
a Buddhist organization The Soca gakkai
as a Peace Museum
in 1962 the
Atomic weapons are all on the missile
was almost
launched
the room was launched yeah according to
the spokesman of this military base said
they were ordered to prepare
then received second order to stop it
one of the American servicemen whose job
was to fire the mace missiles
has since revealed that China was a
nuclear Target during the Cuban Missile
Crisis in 1962
we were told that we had to launch all
the missiles
but we only had one missile headed
towards Russia and we did not see why we
should have to involve the other
countries the captain suggested that
everybody cracked the doors open
so it would take less time to launch a
missile if the doors were cracked open
one of the launch Crews was on the point
of firing their missiles when a duty
officer suspected the order was false
to myself sign the best I was told sent
two men over there with us 45s and they
shoot anybody that tried to Launch
until the situation was resolved and it
would only take like 15 20 seconds to
run the distance between the two command
centers so those two men kept that whole
crew at Bay
uh well we made a decision as what to do
and it wasn't very long maybe two or
three seconds later where a very nervous
major came over the intercom
uh issuing the
Stand Down order
and then we just kind of looked at each
other like
we could have
exterminated the whole planet
the major who had given the launch order
was quietly court-martialed and
dismissed from the Air Force
that morning is just as familiar to me
and as clear as yesterday morning is and
this is 53 years later
and how clearly blue the sky was and it
was just some
very like clouds and there was a perfect
breeze blowing at a perfect temperature
I did not know what the temperature was
but it just felt perfect and we were all
just kind of taking it in and taking in
the smell of the air and
the Sea and the land mixture together
and everything smells so beautiful
it's very interesting because
it shows the cities in China right where
these mace missiles were named that yes
which which ones do we have here this
alcohol Island
so uh within 2 000 kilometers
you find hiking or Beijing
UK and Hong Kong Shanghai
it's Taiwan Taipei and Pyongyang North
Korea
within the range of missile
foreign
[Music]
this is the work of the okanawan
Sculptor kinjo manuru
it's a tribute to the suffering and
resistance of the people of this island
foreign
[Music]
island of JeJu
these symbols have struggled are
hauntingly similar the work of Korean
sculptor KO gilchon represents another
fight of Ireland people for freedom
foreign
[Music]
a semi-tropical sanctuary of unusual
Beauty Jeju Island is a world heritage
site
the government of South Korea declared
it an island of World Peace
but on this island of Peace has been
built one of the most provocative
military bases in the world less than
400 miles from Shanghai
like Okinawa and the Marshall Islands
this is America's front line in its
so-called pivot to Asia
here in once unspoiled ganjong Village
the South Korean Navy has built a base
for American aircraft carriers
nuclear submarines
and destroyers equipped with the Aegis
ballistic missile
aimed at China's defenses
China's lifelines to the world in oil
trade resources depend on shipping that
comes through choke points like this
the U.S pivot into the Asia Pacific is
really intended to create the ability to
put a loaded gun to the head of China
and say you know you will do as we say
otherwise we will be able to restrict we
will be able to shut down choke off your
importation of oil and other resources
whatever
[Music]
okay
for nine years every day often twice a
day these Catholic priests have staged
the mass that blocks the gates of the
new military base on Jeju Island
[Music]
in a country where political
demonstrations can be easily banned
unlike powerful religions the tactic has
produced this spectacle of resistance
tomorrow foreign
has led the fight to Scott the face
being built
and several times suffered Serious
injury
[Applause]
[Music]
I sing four songs every day before
marriage to learn the mess at the end of
the match and the end of rosary
yeah the the content of song is very
beautiful the the writer and the
composer is the musician from this
island so I love him very much and he
gave me the song If I practice
and I became a master to sing that song
because I practice everything well you
you sing it with such passion
come down
sometimes we just wait typhoon
if you sing then to do you have a mask
when the typhoons try oh yeah dude
no exception
what will happen
if this space becomes operational they
have destroyed the environment to
destroyed life of villages
no we should be witness of that
oppression and the violence you know why
do they do it well they'd like to rule
the Pacific area whole area
right they'd like to make China isolated
in this group yeah it means U.S
government want to be emperor of this
world
Quaker call Mr O joins them with his own
ritual of protest
accompanied by an artist called
Wildflower
foreign
this is the center of an Empire that
never speaks its name whose power is
represented in this extraordinary world
map of American military bases
[Music]
4 000 bases in the United States almost
a thousand bases spread across every
continent
the archipelago of Empire the bases that
we have around the world hidden in plain
sight are the the real territory of our
Empire
but at the same time we maintain
independent governments in Japan or
South Korea or Germany
they don't have autonomy when it comes
to foreign policy so it's a very
sophisticated and effective system
uh where whereby we Pat ourselves on the
back for uh helping to Midwife democracy
in Japan and Germany and South Korea and
various other places while keeping the
lid on uh in that we don't know what
these countries would do if they were
fully independent and and the beauty of
this system is that most people pay no
attention to it at all they think it's
just a natural occurrence to have 50 000
American troops in in Japan there's no
country that has better anti-imperial
credit uh cred than the United States
and we are not trying to recreate the
glories of the uh the British Empire
we're arguing that the world is round
we have a global policy
and
All Nations have Global rights no ocean
has ever been dominated the way the U.S
dominates the Pacific Navy and Air Force
uh they claim in the Pearl Harbor
headquarters of the Pacific command they
claim to be responsible for 52 percent
of the Earth surface
and when you look at their logo it shows
an eagle over the Aleutian Islands with
one tail on coming down somewhere near
Seattle and the other coming down right
over Beijing so
Beijing looks at a network of bases a
real archipelago of Empire that's been
built up since the Korean War you have
had and still have an arc of of bases
that start in Australia and go through
the Pacific we have no bases in
Australia you have pine Gap you have
Darwin and you have a new facility in
Western Australia no uh to speak
precisely we have no military bases in
Australia what we do is uh operate with
and in Australian bases yeah but we're
not in the basing business nowadays
there's a growing collection of what are
referred to as Lily Pad bases these are
bases that have typically two 300 troops
no family members
very few amenities and are often quite
secretive they're bases that are
frequently constructed within a foreign
country's base to disguise it and
generally are not referred to as bases
many of these bases have been set up to
combat China's worldwide economic
influence
from these bases the United States
operates a secret army in 147 countries
if you're going to be a free country
rather than given to every gangster
regime in the world you're going to have
to take a risk because the gangsters
they want to they they want to eliminate
good people in the world so they can uh
and in China they want to dominate all
of all of the Far East they want to
dominate just like Japan wanted to
before World War II their goal was to
dominate that part of the world today
because there has been no political
reform in Beijing these guys want to
dominate a huge chunk of the planet
while I struggle Andrew karpenovich
served on America's national defense
panel he's a military strategist and War
planner
you've written that airstrikes and Naval
blockades have a role to play in
punishing China
you've described the need for sea mines
you've described the need for Special
Forces U.S Special Forces and missiles
placed in Islands
this sounds like a preparation for war
our first President George Washington
said if you want peace prepare for war
and essentially what the United States
is doing again is responding to
provocative behavior on the part of
China
and just as we did in the Cold War the
idea was to have a position of military
strength such that your adversaries were
not tempted to act in aggressive ways or
try and employ coercion to get their way
I mean just last week the U.S Navy sent
a guided missile destroyer
into the spratly islands and South China
Sea and what was different about this I
think
was that Chinese Fighters scrambled
that sounds like an escalator
well the uh again from an American
perspective the the escalation was the
Chinese beginning to militarize these
islands in the first place moving its
military capabilities down into that
region uh engaging in provocative
Behavior against uh the commercial
activities and military
forces of other minor countries in the
region that have claimed to those
islands so it's a response to Chinese
intimidation uh rather excuse me how how
is Commerce being intimidated in the
South China Sea there have been no
military forces no military bases there
uh the Chinese except the United States
military base not in the South China Sea
and not even in the Philippines because
the United States withdrew its forces in
the Philippines but the United States is
back in the Philippines the in the
United
route the Philippines where U.S troops
will be stationed on a rotational basis
this threat to China from yet more U.S
bases on its doorstep was not an issue
when an arbitration tribunal ruled
against China's claims to the Strategic
spratly islands in the South China Sea
in 2015 the U.S Navy rehearsed a
blockade that would cut China's
lifelines of oil and trade and raw
materials
the danger of Confrontation Grows by the
day
the U.S Navy is on the doorstep of China
regardless of disputed islands and is
there with low draft ships planes battle
groups
it's right on the doorstep what if
Chinese ships what if the equivalent
was off California
well John we ask ourselves that question
regularly and it's it's important to put
yourself in the other guy's shoes yeah
so look we don't operate in the Pacific
in an effort to scare China to contain
China to backfoot China our operations
and our presence
first of all is warmly welcomed by the
vast majority of the coastal States but
secondly is fully accepted by the
Chinese
Time After Time excuse me is it fully
accepted yes my impression by their by
their words the Chinese person is that
they're scared
and this is what they're scared of a
noose of bases right around China
[Music]
missiles bombers drones warships
a provocation of War
today
I State clearly and with conviction
America's commitment to seek the peace
and security of a world without nuclear
weapons
under Obama nuclear warhead spending has
risen higher than under any president
since the end of the Cold War it's all a
magician's show because at the same time
that Obama is talking about that not
only is he spending a trillion dollars
to modernize U.S nuclear forces but he's
deploying these missile defense systems
to encircle Russia and China which makes
it impossible to get rid of nuclear
weapons in that climate everybody wants
to look like they're tough
see I got to be tough I got to show you
you know I'm not afraid of doing
anything military I'm not afraid of
threatening I'm you know I'm a hairy
chested gorilla and you know and you
don't want to look like you're weak
so what you do is you talk more and more
aggressively
and uh and you let and if you don't want
to do it yourself
because you maybe think it doesn't look
very presidential
you let somebody under you do the
talking
and we have gotten into a state the
United States has gotten into a
situation where there's a lot of
military
you know saber rattling and it's really
being orchestrated from the top yeah
this seems incredibly dangerous all of
this it's an understatement I think but
I agree
when you routinely plan for mass murder
you've become conditioned to it that's
what this is we accept it oh yeah we
have nuclear weapons the defense
secretary he's just announced that there
will be warships and special forces and
plans sent to the Philippines and the
Wall Street journalists describe this as
the Vanguard of a major U.S presence in
Southeast Asia that sounds like where
does this end
what's the purpose I mean where are we
going to stop this process before it
starts a war
and then if the war stars where does
that end
[Music]
the scientific studies that I teach by
the scientists that predict that the
Earth can be made essentially
uninhabitable from nuclear war but
scientists have been begging the Obama
Administration well they wouldn't say
begging but they've made multiple
requests to meet with them discuss these
predictions because they're
peer-reviewed studies and they've been
turned down over and over again
they've been peripherally told that well
we don't think the long-term
environmental consequences of nuclear
war all that important if the immediate
effects of nuclear don't stop it but the
long-term environmental consequences of
nuclear war are liable to wipe out the
human race
in one exchange nuclear exchange between
the U.S and China
what could be the consequences
well let me just give you an example of
what one Chinese
four or five Megaton Warhead would do to
a city in the United States if it got
through
the detonation of that weapon over our
city would instantly ignite about six or
seven hundred square miles on fire
and within 20 to 30 minutes all of those
fires would coalesce into a single
gigantic Firestorm there would be no
escape from it so all the people there
would perish so the U.S with say
hundreds of
nuclear weapons on Chinese cities well
when you combine all the smoke from
these nuclear weapons detonating it
actually creates millions of tons of
smoke Black carbon spoke will rise above
Cloud level into the stratosphere it's
heated by the sun it's acts like a solar
collector and that smoke because of that
will stay there for 10 years or longer
and what the smoke does is to block
swarming sunlight from reaching the
surface of the Earth
and it becomes so cold in a matter of
just a couple weeks that will the
temperatures will fall below freezing
every day for one to three years
and it will become too cold to grow food
crops for at least 10 years or longer
I mean there's there's like a total
disconnect with the changing world
you have a giant Rising power in this
case China
why would you expect a giant Rising
power to not want to have more control
over its Destiny what we should be doing
in my view is trying to cultivate a
sense of friendship and cooperation and
we can have our differences with them if
we think they're doing something in
trade that we don't like let's have it
out with them
but this saber rattling is the worst
thing we can possibly do
it is time to show the whole world that
America is back bigger and better and
stronger than ever before
we don't have victories anymore we used
to have victories but we don't have them
when was the last time
anybody saw us beating let's say China
in a trade deal
they kill us we can't continue to allow
China to rape our country and that's
what they're doing it's the greatest
theft in the history of the world
the new president Donald Trump has a
problem with China
the Urgent question now is Will trump
continue with the provocations revealed
in this film and take us all to the edge
of War
there never have been two countries
more interdependent on each other
than China in the US in history
uh and China is the largest trading
nation in the world and in history
so China's economy and and their society
their lives are are linked to the entire
world including America and the west and
all the other countries so so I think
interdependence between these two
countries and among all the nations of
the world uh speak to peace
foreign
[Music]
we don't have to accept the word of
those who conjure up threats and false
enemies that justify the business and
profit of War
if we recognize there is another
superpower
and that's us
ordinary people everywhere like the
people of Okinawa Jeju Island the
Marshall Islands China the United States
by speaking out they deliver a warning
to all of us
can we really afford to be silent
we
again
don't know where
but I know we'll meet again
some sunny days
[Applause]
smiling through
just like you
you always do
till the blue skies drive the dark
clouds far away
so will you please say hello to the
folks that I know tell them I won't
belong
[Music]
they'll be happy to know that as you saw
me go I was singing this song
[Music]
eat again
don't know where
don't know what and but I know we'll
meet again
some sunny days
[Music]
[Applause]
please smile through just like you
[Music]
are
your grace
[Music]
inside
we'll please
[Music]
[Applause]